Here's my seventh grade teacher's sad fate-- he trained as a classical musician, loved music, truly loved it. And then every working day, he surrounded himself with 13-year-olds who massacred the living guts out of it. Could not play it and did not care. It made him the angriest teacher I ever saw. He yelled all the time. This is what happens if you believe that music means something, is important, and you're surrounded all day long with 13- and 14-year-olds who demonstrate through their actions that maybe it's not.
这是我七年级老师悲惨命运的写照——他曾受过古典音乐家的训练，热爱音乐，真心热爱。然后，每个工作日他都被一群13岁的孩子包围，这些孩子把音乐摧残得体无完肤。他们演奏不出美感，也根本不在乎。这让他成为我见过最愤怒的老师。他总是大吼大叫。如果你相信音乐意味着什么、很重要，而整天被一群13、14岁的孩子包围，且他们的行为又证明音乐或许并不重要，那就会发生这样的事。
I told Durrell Daniels about him and Durrell understood immediately. Durrell was once paid to teach band, but he had to quit because he looked at the facts at hand and came to the simple conclusion--
我向杜雷尔·丹尼尔斯提起过他，杜雷尔立刻就明白了。杜雷尔曾经受雇教乐队，但他不得不辞职，因为他审视了手头的现实，得出了一个简单的结论——
I got out of band teaching because I noticed that all the band teachers I knew had went a little crazy. I mean, no disrespect intended, but you don't find too many, like, totally sane band teachers who have taught band for a long time. And I sort of saw myself going on the edge. And I said, well, no. I don't want to be whistling to myself at a wall, looking at apples that are not there, or something like that. Because it's sort of like-- no instrument sounds good when it's not played well. Trumpet was a pain. Saxophone was a pain. Clarinet was hell.
我不教乐队了，因为我注意到我认识的所有乐队老师都有点疯了。我的意思是，并无不敬之意，但你找不到太多长期教乐队且完全正常的老师。我看到自己也快要崩溃了。于是我说，不，我可不想对着墙自言自语，对着并不存在的苹果发呆，或者类似的事情。因为这就像是……没有哪种乐器在没练好时是好听的。小号简直是折磨。萨克斯风也是折磨。单簧管简直是地狱。
And another thing. The kids, when they get a trumpet, there's a difference between a kid singing and a kid getting a trumpet. You might can't sing, and you might be a little shy. No kid's going to be shy about blowing that horn no matter how bad they sound.
还有一件事。孩子们拿到小号时，孩子唱歌和孩子吹小号是有区别的。你可能不会唱歌，也可能有点害羞。但无论吹得多么难听，没有孩子会在吹号时感到害羞。
As a professional musician, Durrell played jazz and funk and soul, keyboards and vocals. He's toured Asia and Brazil and Canada. He's done gigs in Paris. But four years ago, with kids to support of his own, he returned to a music job in the Chicago Public Schools in an elementary school.
作为一名职业音乐人，杜雷尔演奏爵士、放克和灵魂乐，擅长键盘和声乐。他曾在亚洲、巴西和加拿大巡演。他在巴黎演出过。但四年前，因为要抚养自己的孩子，他回到了芝加哥公立学校的一所小学从事音乐教学工作。
And we get these little records, Barney records. And we get up and do a little Barney dance. I'm like, this sucks.
我们拿到这些小唱片，巴尼（Barney）唱片。我们起来跳一段小小的巴尼舞。我就想，这简直糟透了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And you had already, at that point, you had toured. God, there should be a name for this, like for that moment.
那时候，你已经进行过巡演了。天哪，应该给这种时刻起个名字，比如那一刻的感觉。
Misery. That's the name.
苦难。就是这个名字。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, coming to you today from the Yerba Buena Center for the Arts in San Francisco, California, thanks to public radio station KQED in San Francisco. Today on our program, Music Lessons. What's frustrating about them, what's miraculous about them.
欢迎收听由WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台制作的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯，今天在加利福尼亚州旧金山的耶尔巴布埃纳艺术中心为您主持节目，感谢旧金山KQED公共广播电台。今天节目的主题是：音乐课。谈谈它们的沮丧之处，以及它们的奇妙之处。
Act One, Papa Was not a Rolling Stone. David Sedaris tells what happens when a parent does not play an instrument and insists that his children take lessons. Act Two. Toccata and Fugue in Me, a Minor. Sarah Vowell recalls all the things that she learned in music class that had nothing to do with music. Act Three, Knockin' on Heaven's Door, in which Annie Lamott provides some much needed spiritual uplift to our program with an example of what we can learn from music now, all of us. Stay with us.
第一幕，《爸爸不是滚石乐队成员》。大卫·塞达里斯讲述了当一位家长自己不玩乐器，却坚持让孩子上课时会发生什么。第二幕，《D小调托卡塔与赋格》。萨拉·沃威尔回忆了她在音乐课上学到的所有与音乐无关的事情。第三幕，《敲响天堂之门》，安妮·拉莫特为我们的节目带来了一些急需的精神慰藉，用一个例子展示了我们现在能从音乐中学到什么。请继续收听。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
So imagine that you're an adult and you decide you want to express yourself through music. And the medium that you have to express yourself is 13- and 14- and 15-year-old kids. That is a very imprecise medium in which to apply your art. This week was especially hard on Durrell. He had to get one group of kids rehearsed to sing at one graduation ceremony and another group ready for another graduation ceremony and then there were some recitals to do.
想象一下，你是一个成年人，决定通过音乐表达自我。而你用来表达的媒介是13、14和15岁的孩子。对于表达艺术来说，这是一种非常不精确的媒介。这周对杜雷尔来说尤其艰难。他必须让一组孩子排练在毕业典礼上唱歌，另一组为另一场毕业典礼做准备，还要举办几场演奏会。
And then the gospel choir, who usually is pride and joy kids, sort of fell apart on him. They were singing badly. They were arguing with him. He sat them down. He told them he was probably going to have to cancel their last concert of the year. But he would decide about it after one last rehearsal.
还有福音合唱团，他们通常是孩子们的骄傲和快乐，却在他面前分崩离析。他们唱得很糟糕。他们和他争吵。他让他们坐下。他告诉他们，他可能不得不取消他们今年最后一场音乐会。但他会在最后一次排练后再做决定。
My kids-- I was like, look, I'm tired. I'm tired. I've been working this stuff for you guys. And look, I can't sit here and argue with all you almost-grown kids all day long.
我的孩子们——我就像说，听着，我累了。我累了。我一直在为你们做这些事。看，我不能整天坐在这里跟你们这些快长大的孩子们吵架。
[KIDS REHEARSING]
[孩子们排练中]
All right. Come on. Let's get together.
好了。来吧。大家集中一下。
After school Tuesday, the gospel choir gathered in Lindblom's Auditorium, 22 girls and three boys, one boy who never seemed to sing at all.
周二放学后，福音合唱团在林德布洛姆礼堂集合，有22个女孩和3个男孩，其中一个男孩似乎从不唱歌。
All right, you guys. Let's get into sections.
好了，各位。我们分组吧。
Everybody was on their best behavior. They wanted to show Mr. Daniels that they could do the concert. And they began their practice the way that they always do, with a prayer.
每个人都表现得最好。他们想向丹尼尔斯先生展示他们能完成音乐会。他们像往常一样开始了练习，先做一个祷告。
Father God, right now in the name of Jesus, God, we come thanking you, O God. We want to thank you for gathering us here, O God. We come against every spirit that's trying to hinder this choir right now in the name of Jesus.
天父，此时此刻以耶稣的名义，上帝，我们感谢你。我们要感谢你召集我们在这里。上帝，我们要抵挡此时此刻任何试图阻碍这个合唱团的灵，奉耶稣的名。
And then from the moment that they started to sing, they just soared. They were great.
从他们开始唱歌的那一刻起，他们就腾飞了。他们唱得太棒了。
[SINGING] Clap your hands.
[歌唱] 拍拍你的手。
One, two, three, four!
一，二，三，四！
Hey!
嘿！
Teaching music is like any teaching, except that when you fail, it is loud. And failure is so easy. Every note is a chance to mess up. After three songs, Mr. Daniels told the chorus that he would not cancel the concert. Now he just had to get through two graduations, their concert, and a couple of recitals, and he could have the summer to promote his new CD, which, like any real professional musician, he asked me to mention here on the radio.
教音乐和任何教学一样，除了当你失败时，声音会特别大。而失败是如此容易。每一个音符都有可能搞砸。三首歌唱完后，丹尼尔斯先生告诉合唱团他不会取消音乐会。现在他只需要熬过两场毕业典礼、他们的音乐会和几场演奏会，他就可以利用暑假来推广他的新CD，就像任何真正的职业音乐人一样，他让我在这里提一下。
Act One, Papa Was not a Rolling Stone. Children are asked to live the unlived lives of their parents nowhere more than music lessons. There the eager music students and then there are the reluctant music students. This is the story of somebody in the second group. Please welcome writer David Sedaris.
第一幕，《爸爸不是滚石乐队成员》。孩子最常被迫去过父母未曾过上的生活的地方，莫过于音乐课。那里有渴望上音乐课的学生，也有不情愿的学生。这是属于第二类人的故事。欢迎作家大卫·塞达里斯。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
My father loves jazz and has a substantial collection of records and reel-to-reel tapes he used to listen to after returning home from work each evening. He might have entered the house in a foul mood, but once he had his Dexter Gordon and a vodka martini, everything was beautiful, baby. Just beautiful. The moment the needle hit that record, he loosened his tie and became something other than a mechanical engineer with a pocket full of IBM pencils embossed with the word "think."
我父亲热爱爵士乐，拥有大量唱片和卷盘磁带收藏，他每天下班回家后都会听。他进门时心情可能很糟糕，但一旦有了德克斯特·戈登的音乐和伏特加马提尼，一切就都变得美妙了，宝贝。真的非常美妙。唱针落到唱片上的那一刻，他松开领带，不再是那个口袋里塞满了印着“思考”字样的IBM铅笔的机械工程师。
"Man, oh, man. Will you get a load of the chops on this guy? I saw him once at the Blue Note, and I mean to tell you that he blew me right out of my chair. You could take a hatchet and cut the man's lips right off his face, and still he would have played better than anyone else out there. That's how good he was!"
“伙计，天哪。你听听这人的技巧？我曾经在蓝调之音（Blue Note）见过他，我告诉你，他吹奏出的音乐直接把我震得从椅子上掉下来。就算你拿把斧头把这家伙的嘴唇砍掉，他依然能吹得比外面任何人都好。他就是这么厉害！”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'd nod my head, envisioning a pair of lips lying forsaken on the floor of some dressing room. The trick was to back slowly towards the hallway, escaping into the kitchen before my father could yell, "hey, get back here! Where do you think you're going? Sit down for a minute and listen. I mean, really listen."
我会点头，想象着一双嘴唇孤零零地躺在某个更衣室地板上的样子。诀窍是慢慢地退向走廊，在父亲喊出“嘿，回来！你以为你要去哪？坐下一会儿听听。我是说，认真听”之前溜进厨房。
How could you prove you were listening? It was as if he expected us to change color like the fuzz-colored ceramic rabbit our neighbor used to predict the weather. I often thought that my father might have been a musician himself had he not been born to immigrant parents who considered even wax-tipped shoelaces to be an extravagance. They listened only to Greek music, an oxymoron as far as the rest of the world was concerned.
你该如何证明你在听呢？就好像他期望我们像邻居用来预报天气的绒毛色陶瓷兔子那样变色。我经常想，如果父亲不是出生在那种连打蜡鞋带都认为是奢侈品的移民家庭，他自己可能也会成为一名音乐家。他们只听希腊音乐，就世界其他地方而言，这简直是个自相矛盾的说法。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Jazz was, in a sense, my father's own personal discovery. Denounced and forbidden by his parents, he hid his 78s and secretly drove into New York City, where he'd sit alive and enraptured at the feet of his heroes. The move to North Carolina was difficult, and he felt cut off with nothing but the Country and Top 40 radio stations Raleigh had to offer in the mid to late 1960s. Limited to his record collection, it became his dream that his children might fill the void by someday forming a jazz combo.
某种意义上，爵士乐是我父亲个人的发现。因为父母的谴责和禁止，他藏起他的78转唱片，秘密开车去纽约，在那里坐在他偶像的脚边，心醉神迷。搬到北卡罗来纳州的过程很艰难，他感到与世隔绝，在1960年代中后期，罗利市只有乡村音乐和热门前40电台可听。受限于自己的唱片收藏，他的梦想是孩子们有一天能通过组成爵士乐队来填补这一空白。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
His plan took shape shortly after escorting my sisters Lisa, Gretchen, and I to the local state university to see Dave Brubeck, who was currently touring with his sons. The audience roared when Dave Brubeck stepped forth from behind the curtain, and I sat back, pretending those applauds were for me. A person had to do something while standing before a crowd of 600 people. And with this in mind, I'd been secretly working up a little routine. The act consisted of me dressed in a nice shirt and tie and performing a medley of commercial jingles in the voice of Billie Holiday.
他的计划是在陪我和姐妹丽莎、格雷琴去当地州立大学看戴夫·布鲁贝克（Dave Brubeck）演出后形成的，当时布鲁贝克正带着他的儿子们巡演。当戴夫·布鲁贝克从幕后走出来时，观众欢呼雀跃，而我坐在后面，假装那些掌声是给我的。站在600人的人群前，总得做点什么。考虑到这一点，我私下里准备了一个小节目。表演内容是我穿着漂亮的衬衫和领带，用比莉·哈乐黛（Billie Holiday）的声音演唱一段商业广告歌串烧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For my Raleigh show, I'd probably open with the number used to promote our town's oldest shopping center. A quick nod to my accompanist and I'd begin with, [SINGING] "the excitement of Cameron Village will carry you a-way."
在罗利的表演中，我可能会以推广我们镇最古老购物中心的广告歌开场。向我的伴奏点点头，我开始唱：[歌唱]“卡梅伦村的兴奋将带你飞向远方。”
[LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE]
[笑声] [掌声]
The beauty of my rendition was that it captured both the joy and the sorrow of a visit to Ellisburg's or JCPenney's. This would be followed by such sure-fire hits as the theme for Winston cigarettes and the catchy new Coke commercial. [SINGING] "I'd like to teach the world to sing in perfect harmony. I'd like to buy the world a Coke and keep it company."
我演绎的精髓在于，它捕捉到了去埃利斯堡或杰西潘尼百货购物时的喜悦与忧伤。紧随其后的是像温斯顿香烟主题曲和那首朗朗上口的可口可乐新广告歌这样的必杀曲目。[歌唱]“我愿教世界歌唱，在完美的和声中。我愿买世界一瓶可乐，让它陪伴左右。”
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I was lost in my fantasy, ignoring Dave Brubeck and coming up for air only when my father elbowed my ribs to say, "are you listening to this? These cats are burnin' the paint right off the walls!" Driving home from the concert that night, he had drummed his fingers against the steering wheel, saying, "did you hear that? The guy just gets better every day! There he was with his kids, the whole lot of them, jamming up a storm. What I wouldn't give for a family like that. You guys should think about putting an act together."
我沉浸在幻想中，无视了戴夫·布鲁贝克，只有当父亲用肘部捅我的肋骨说“你在听吗？这些家伙简直要把墙上的油漆烧没了！”我才回到现实。那天晚上从演唱会回家的路上，他在方向盘上敲着手指说：“听到了吗？那家伙每天都在进步！他带着孩子们在那里，他们全都一起即兴演奏，简直太棒了。为了这样一个家庭我什么都愿意做。你们几个应该考虑组个乐队。”
The following afternoon, he bought a baby grand piano. It sat neglected until my father signed Gretchen up for a series of lessons. Lisa was assigned the flute. And I returned home from a scout meeting one evening to find my instrument leaning against the aquarium in my bedroom. "So there she is," my father said. "Here's that guitar you always wanted." Surely he had me confused with someone else. While I had regularly petitioned for a brand-name vacuum cleaner, I had never said anything about wanting a guitar.
第二天下午，他买了一架三角钢琴。它一直被冷落，直到父亲给格雷琴报了一系列课程。丽莎被分配了长笛。一天晚上，我从童子军聚会回家，发现我的乐器靠在卧室的鱼缸旁。“就在那儿，”父亲说，“这就是你一直想要的吉他。”他肯定把我跟别人搞混了。虽然我经常请求买一台名牌吸尘器，但我从未说过想要吉他。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Nothing about it appealed to me. I had my room arranged just so, and it didn't fit in at all with the nautical theme.
它对我一点吸引力都没有。我的房间布置得井井有条，它和航海主题一点也不搭。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I stuffed it into my closet and there it remained until he signed me up for private lessons. "But I'm sick!" I yelled, watching him pull out of the parking lot. "I don't want to play an instrument. Don't you know anything?" I lugged my guitar into the music shop, where the manager led me to my teacher, a temperamental midget named Mr. Mancini.
我把它塞进壁橱，它就一直呆在那里，直到他给我报了私人课程。“但我病了！”我喊道，看着他把车开出停车场。“我不想玩乐器。你难道什么都不懂吗？”我拖着吉他走进乐器店，经理把我带到了我的老师面前——一个名叫曼奇尼先生的暴躁侏儒。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
A fastidious dresser stuck in a small town, Mr. Mancini wore clothing I recognized from the young boys department at Hudson Belk's. Some nights he favored button-up shirts with clip-on ties, while other evenings I arrived to find him dressed in flared slacks and a snug turtleneck sweater, a swag of love beads hanging from his neck. His arms were manly and covered in coarse dark hair, but his voice was high and strange, as if it had been recorded and played back at a higher speed.
曼奇尼先生是一个困在小镇里的考究着装者，他穿的衣服我能在哈德逊贝尔克百货的童装部认出来。有些晚上他喜欢穿带扣领的衬衫系着夹式领带，而其他晚上我见到他时，他穿着喇叭裤和紧身的高领毛衣，脖子上挂着一串和平符号项链。他的手臂粗壮且长满了粗糙的黑毛，但他的声音却很高且怪异，就像是被录下来并调快了速度回放一样。
My fascination was both evident and unwelcome. He didn't ask my name, just lit a cigarette and squinted against the smoke. Like my father, Mr. Mancini assumed that anyone could play guitar. He had picked it up during a single summer spent in what he called "Hot-lanta, G-A." "Now that," he said, "is one classy city. You know what I mean? The girls down on Peachtree are running wild 24 hours a day."
我的好奇心既显而易见又不受欢迎。他没问我的名字，只是点了一支烟，在烟雾中眯起眼睛。像我父亲一样，曼奇尼先生认为任何人都能弹吉他。他是在他在所谓“佐治亚州亚特兰大”度过的一个夏天里学会的。“那是，”他说，“一座非常时髦的城市。你知道我的意思吗？桃树街上的姑娘们24小时都在狂欢。”
"That's great," I said. He seemed to know that I was nothing special but just a type, another boy whose father had his head in the clouds.
“那太棒了，”我说。他似乎知道我没什么特别的，只是那种典型的、父亲头脑发热的孩子。
"Let me show you what this instrument's all about." He climbed into his chair and began playing "Light My Fire." The current Top 40 version was performed by Jose Feliciano, a blind man whose plaintive voice served the lyric much better than Jim Morrison, who sang the song in what I considered to be a bossy and conceited tone of voice.
“让我展示一下这个乐器的精髓。”他坐到椅子上，开始弹奏《点燃我的火焰》（Light My Fire）。当时热门前40的版本是何塞·费利西亚诺（Jose Feliciano）演唱的，他是一位盲人，他那哀婉的声音比吉姆·莫里森更适合这首歌词，我认为莫里森唱这首歌的语气傲慢又自负。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The was Jose Feliciano, Jim Morrison, and then there was Mr. Mancini, who played beautifully but sang "Light My Fire" as if he were a Webelos Scout searching for a match.
那是何塞·费利西亚诺，吉姆·莫里森，然后是曼奇尼先生，他弹得很好，但唱《点燃我的火焰》时就像一个正在找火柴的韦伯洛幼童军。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He finished his opening number, nodded his head in acknowledgement of my applause, and moved on, performing his own unique an unsettling versions of "The Girl From Ipanema" and "Little Green Apples," while I sat in my seat, a fault smile stretched so tight I lost all feeling in my jaw. My fingernails had grown a good three inches by the time he hit his final note and called me close to point out a few simple chords. Before leaving, he gave me some purple, mimeographed handouts which we both knew were useless.
他弹完了开场曲，点头回应我的掌声，然后继续表演他自己独特且令人不安的《伊帕内玛姑娘》和《红苹果》，而我坐在座位上，脸上拉扯出一个僵硬的假笑，导致我的下巴都麻木了。当他弹出最后一个音符并叫我靠近指出几个简单的和弦时，我的指甲已经长了足足三英寸。离开前，他给了我一些紫色的油印讲义，我们都知道那根本没用。
Back at the house, my mother had my dinner warming in the oven. From the living room, I could hear the aimless whisper of Lisa's flute, which sounded much like the wind whipping through an empty Pepsi can.
回到家，母亲在烤箱里热着我的晚餐。从客厅里，我能听到丽莎长笛漫无目的的嘶鸣，听起来就像风吹过空百事可乐罐。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Down in the basement, Gretchen was either practicing piano or the cat was chasing a moth across the keys. I was at the mall with my mother, afternoon, when I spotted Mr. Mancini reaching up to order a hamburger at Scotty's Chuckwagon, an open-air fast food restaurant located a few doors down from the music shop. He was standing on his tiptoes, and even then his head failed to reach the counter. Once he'd gotten his food, he carried his tray towards a vacant table facing the escalator. The passing adults shifted their gaze or smiled politely while their children were decidedly more overt. Toddlers ambled up on their chubby, bowed legs, embracing my teacher with their ketchup-smeared fingers.
在地下室里，格雷琴要么是在练钢琴，要么是猫在琴键上追逐飞蛾。一天下午我和母亲在商场里，看到曼奇尼先生正踮着脚尖在斯科蒂马车餐厅点汉堡，那是一家离乐器店只有几步之遥的露天快餐店。他踮着脚尖，即便如此，他的头还是够不到柜台。拿到食物后，他端着托盘走向一张对着自动扶梯的空桌子。路过的成年人移开视线或礼貌地微笑，而他们的孩子们则明显直白得多。蹒跚学步的孩子们用胖乎乎、弯曲的腿走过来，用沾满番茄酱的手指拥抱我的老师。
It suddenly became clear that Mr. Mancini hated children. The only thing worse were the adolescents, the boys my age who sat at the surrounding tables poking fun and regurgitating their Scotty fries in laughter. Watching this scene from a distance, my first thought was hey, that's my midget. Hands off! The man was my discovery, not theirs. I'd always thought of him as a pocket Playboy, but watching him dip his hamburger into a puddle of mayonnaise, I broadened my view and saw him as a vulnerable loner, an outsider who scoffed not only at Raleigh but at the entire state of North Carolina. It was a persona I'd thought of adopting myself.
突然间我明白曼奇尼先生讨厌孩子。唯一比这更糟的是那些青少年，坐在周围桌子上的和我同龄的男孩，他们嘲笑并大笑着喷出斯科蒂炸薯条。从远处看着这一幕，我的第一个念头是：嘿，那是我的侏儒。别碰他！这个人是我的发现，不是他们的。我一直把他看作袖珍版的《花花公子》模特，但看着他把汉堡蘸进一滩蛋黄酱里，我拓宽了视野，把他看作一个脆弱的独行者，一个不仅嘲笑罗利，而且嘲笑整个北卡罗来纳州的局外人。这是一个我曾想自己采用的形象。
Looking at it this way, it seemed that Mr. Mancini and I actually had quite a bit in common. We were both men trapped in boys' bodies. There was no reason I shouldn't address him not as a teacher but as an artistic brother. If things worked out the way I hoped, maybe I could even use him as my accompanist.
这样看，我和曼奇尼先生其实有很多共同点。我们都是困在男孩身体里的男人。我不应该把他当作老师，而应该当作艺术上的兄弟。如果事情如我所愿，也许我甚至可以让他做我的伴奏。
The following evening, I showed up for my lesson. And this time, when asked if I'd practiced, I told the truth, saying in a matter-of-fact tone of voice that no, I had not touched the thing since the last session. I told him that I had absolutely no interest in mastering the guitar. What I really wanted to do was sing in the voice of Billie Holiday, mainly commercials, but not for any banks or car dealerships, because those are usually choral arrangements. The color ebbed from my teacher's face. I told him I'd been working up an act and could use a little accompaniment. Did he know the jingle for the new Sara Lee campaign?
第二天晚上，我去上课。这一次，当被问及是否练习时，我说了实话，用一种公事公办的口气说，没有，自上次上课以来我连都没碰过那东西。我告诉他，我对比吉他一点兴趣都没有。我真正想做的是用比莉·哈乐黛的声音唱歌，主要是广告歌，但不是为银行或汽车经销商唱，因为那通常是合唱编排。老师脸上的血色褪去了。我告诉他我一直在准备一个节目，可以用一点伴奏。他知道莎莉（Sara Lee）新广告的那个短曲吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He acted as though I had instructed him to do something unspeakable perverse. "You want me to what?" I was certain he was lying when he told me he didn't know the tune. Doublemint gum, Ritz crackers, the themes for Alka-Seltzer and Kenmore appliances, he claimed ignorant on all counts. I knew that it was queer to sing in front of someone, but seeing as he'd been doing it for weeks, I started in on an a cappella version of the latest Oscar Mayer commercial hoping he might join in once the spirit moved him.
他表现得好像我让他做了一件不可言说的变态事。“你要我做什么？”当他告诉我他不知道那首歌时，我肯定他在撒谎。双果味口香糖、丽兹饼干、Alka-Seltzer和Kenmore家电的主题曲，他全都装作不知道。我知道在别人面前唱歌很怪，但鉴于他已经这样做了几周，我开始清唱最新的奥斯卡·迈耶（Oscar Mayer）广告歌，希望他能在心血来潮时加入进来。
With a total disregard for his company, I sang the same way I did at home when alone in my bedroom. My eyes shut tight and my hands moving in a useless and crippled fashion. [SINGING] "My bologna has a first name. It's O-S-C-A-R. My bologna has a second name. It's M-A-Y-E-R. Oh, I love to eat it every day. And if you ask me why, I'll say that Oscar Mayer has a way with B-O-L-O-G-N-A."
我不顾他的反应，唱得和我独自在卧室里一样。我的眼睛紧闭，双手做着无用而扭曲的动作。[歌唱]“我的博洛尼亚香肠有一个名字。叫O-S-C-A-R。我的博洛尼亚香肠有第二个名字。叫M-A-Y-E-R。哦，我每天都爱吃它。如果你问我为什么，我会说奥斯卡·迈耶有办法处理B-O-L-O-G-N-A。”
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I reached the end of the tune, thinking he might take this as an opportunity to applaud or maybe even apologize for underestimating me. But instead, he held up his hand, saying, "hey guy, I'm not into that scene. There were plenty of screwballs like you back in Atlanta. And I don't know, I guess it's your thing, or whatever, but you can definitely count me out."
我唱完了曲子，心想他也许会借此机会鼓掌，或者甚至为低估我而道歉。但他却举起手说：“嘿伙计，我对那一套不感兴趣。亚特兰大有的是像你这样的怪人。我不知道，我想那是你的风格，不管怎样，但肯定别算上我。”
My father was disappointed when I told him I wouldn't be returning for any more lessons. Luckily my sisters were as fed up as I was, and we approached him together, saying that the Sedaris trio had officially dismantled. He offered to find us better teachers, adding in that if we were unhappy with our instruments, we could always trade them in for something livelier. "The trumpet or saxophone or hey, how about the vibes?" He reached for a Lionel Hampton album, saying, "let me play you a little something I think you're going to love."
当我告诉父亲我不再去上课时，他很失望。幸运的是，我的姐妹们和我一样受够了，我们一起走过去告诉他，塞达里斯三重奏正式解散了。他提出帮我们找更好的老师，并补充说，如果我们对乐器不满意，总可以换成更活泼的。“小号或萨克斯风，或者嘿，颤音琴怎么样？”他拿起一张莱昂内尔·汉普顿（Lionel Hampton）的唱片说：“让我给你放点我觉得你会喜欢的东西。”
We told him, no Dad, don't bother. But still, he readied the stereo, holding the record to the light and examining it for dust. "I'm telling you that this record is going to change your life. And if it doesn't, I'll give each one of you $5. How do you like that?"
我们对他说，不，爸爸，别费心了。但他还是准备好音响，把唱片对着光检查是否有灰尘。“我告诉你，这张唱片会改变你的一生。如果没改变，我给你们每人5美元。这样好吗？”
It was a tough call. Five dollars for listening to a Lionel Hampton album. Yet we knew that there were certainly strings attached. We looked at each other, my sisters and I. And then we left the room, failing to respond as he yelled, "hey, where do you think you're going? Get back in here and listen!" We joined our mother at the TV and never looked back. The music was his great fantasy, not ours.
这是一个艰难的抉择。为了听一张莱昂内尔·汉普顿的唱片得5美元。然而我们知道肯定有附加条件。我们面面相觑，我和我的姐妹们。然后我们离开了房间，没理会他在后面大喊：“嘿，你们以为要去哪？回来听！”我们和母亲一起看电视，再也没有回头。音乐是他的伟大幻想，不是我们的。
That night, as was his habit, our father fell asleep in front of the stereo, the record making its pointless, silent rounds as he laid back against the sofa cushions dreaming. Thank you.
那天晚上，像往常一样，父亲在音响前睡着了，唱片在他靠在沙发垫上做梦时，进行着毫无意义的静默循环。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
David Sedaris is the author of several books. His book of stories, Naked , just came out in paperback. Coming up, Sarah Vowell marches, Anne Lamott prays. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues. It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of different writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today we come to you from the Yerba Buena Center for the Arts in San Francisco, California.
大卫·塞达里斯著有多部书。他的故事集《赤裸》（Naked）刚刚出了平装本。接下来，萨拉·沃威尔游行，安妮·拉莫特祈祷。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，请听国际公共广播电台的报道。这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的作家和表演者来探讨。今天我们从加利福尼亚州旧金山的耶尔巴布埃纳艺术中心为您广播。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Today's program, Music Lessons. What makes them so great, what makes them so terrible, what we really, really, really learn from them. We have arrived at Act Two of our program.
今天的节目主题是：音乐课。是什么让它们如此伟大，是什么让它们如此糟糕，我们究竟从中学到了什么。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Toccata and Fugue in Me, a Minor. As a teenager growing up in Montana, Sarah Vowell was not casual about music lessons. She was not reluctant about music lessons. Music became her life. She was in marching band, band 1, symphony band, jazz band, pep band, orchestra, and the Bozeman Recorder Ensemble. She's now a music writer and one of our contributing editors at This American Life . Please welcome her.
第二幕，《D小调托卡塔与赋格》。作为在蒙大拿州长大的少年，萨拉·沃威尔对音乐课并不随便。她对音乐课并不排斥。音乐成了她的生命。她参加过行进乐队、一号乐队、交响乐团、爵士乐队、加油乐队、管弦乐队和波兹曼竖笛合奏团。她现在是一位音乐作家，也是《美国生活》的特约编辑之一。欢迎她。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
It was autumn in America, a fine, hot, Indian Summer day. Pretty high school girls sat on bleachers with the sun shining on their pretty hair, watching handsome high school boys play football. And then it was halftime, which is where I came in. I was standing in line in my silver spats down past the end zone waiting to go on. I was in 11th grade. I was in marching band.
那是美国的秋天，一个晴朗、炎热的印第安夏日。漂亮的女生坐在看台上，阳光照在她们美丽的头发上，看着英俊的男生踢足球。然后是中场休息，那就是我登场的地方。我穿着银色的绑腿，站在达阵区外排队等待上场。那时我上11年级。我是行进乐队成员。
I had a foot-tall, fake fur, black hat with the vaguely-processed-food-named shako strapped under my chin that not only prevented me from breathing, it prevented me from balancing, so that even though my job was to march around as some kind of sick metaphor for teenage military precision, I moved through time and space with the grace and confidence of a puppy walking on a beach ball.
我戴着一顶一英尺高、假毛的黑色高筒帽，名字听起来像某种加工食品，帽带紧紧勒在下巴下。它不仅阻止我呼吸，还让我无法保持平衡。所以即使我的工作是行进在场上，作为某种青少年军事精确度的病态隐喻，但我走起来的姿态和自信，就像一只走在沙滩球上的小狗。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because of my double shortage of strength and coordination, I barely passed gym. But somehow I was supposed to lift a baritone horn that measured twice my body weight, blow into it while reading microscopic sheet music, step in a straight line while remembering left foot on beats one and three, right foot on beats two and four, and maneuver myself into cute, visual formations like the trio of stick figures when we played the theme from My Three Sons.
因为力量和协调性的双重匮乏，我勉强通过了体育课。但不知何故，我被要求举起一个重量是我体重两倍的上低音号，在吹奏的同时阅读微小的乐谱，在记住节奏一和三左脚、节奏二和四右脚的同时保持直线行进，并将自己编队进可爱的视觉图形中，比如我们在演奏《我的三个儿子》主题曲时，那个三根火柴人组成的队列。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then, halfway through the halftime program, I had to break formation, drop my baritone horn on the field, and sprint to the 50-yard line, a long haul, with everyone in the band, everyone in the bleachers, everyone on the sidelines watching and waiting, silent and still. And then I picked up my mallets. This is what they had been waiting for, a xylophone solo on a little Latin-flavored number called, "Tico-Tico."
然后，在中场表演进行到一半时，我必须打破队形，把上低音号扔在场上，然后冲向50码线，那是一段漫长的距离，乐队里的每个人、看台上的每个人、边线上的每个人都盯着我看，静止不动。然后我拿起琴槌。这就是他们一直等待的，在一段名为《Tico-Tico》的拉丁风格小曲子上的木琴独奏。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My polo-shirt-clad nemesis, Andy Heap, stood up in the stands screaming, "Vowell, Vowell, woo, woo!" as the laughter of his friends-- at me-- drowned out the horn section. This was the same Andy Heap, I might add, who earlier in the week in music history class had delivered an oral report on Tchaikovsky's mistress and referred to her as Mimi throughout, even though her name was Nadia. Andy Heap was apparently smart enough to publicly humiliate me during "Tico-Tico," he just wasn't smart enough to know that the abbreviation M-M-E-period stands not for Mimi but the title "Madame."
我的穿着polo衫的克星，安迪·希普，站在看台上尖叫：“沃威尔，沃威尔，呜，呜！”当他的朋友们——嘲笑我——的笑声淹没了圆号部分。我不得不提一下，这个安迪·希普，就是在本周早些时候的音乐史课上，就柴可夫斯基的情妇做了口头报告，并自始至终称她为“米米”（Mimi），尽管她的名字叫纳迪亚。安迪·希普显然聪明到足以在《Tico-Tico》表演期间公开羞辱我，他只是不够聪明，不知道缩写M-M-E.不是米米，而是“夫人”（Madame）的尊称。
[LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE]
[笑声] [掌声]
Anyway, I only had a second to stick out my tongue at Andy when I finished because I had to let go of the mallets, rush over to my baritone-- again the freeze-framed spectators, the loneliness of the long distance runner, --and I'm back in formation with the low brass for the finale. And I was getting academic credit for this. I was getting graded to wear that uniform, to play those songs. Which begs the question, what exactly was I supposed to be learning? What was marching band supposed to teach me?
总之，表演结束时我只有一秒钟的时间向安迪吐舌头，因为我必须放下琴槌，冲向我的上低音号——又是那些定格的观众，那个长跑选手的孤独——我得回到铜管乐器组完成终曲。而且我还在为这个拿学分。我因为穿那套制服、吹那些曲子而得到评分。这引发了一个问题，我到底应该学到什么？行进乐队到底应该教我什么？
And marching is not a particularly applicable skill in later life. And ditto all the other handy things music classes taught me-- the E-flat minor scale, the alternate fingering for D-sharp. Here, then, some of the lessons, actually useful ones, I accidentally learned while pursuing music.
行进并不是后半生特别适用的技能。音乐课教给我的其他方便技巧也一样——降E小调音阶，升D的交替指法。那么，以下是我在追求音乐时意外学到的一些真正有用的经验。
Accidental lesson number one-- Marxism for 10th graders. Once a week, the best band kids played with the orchestra. I played the bass drum in orchestra, which meant that I never got to play. My participation ratio was something like 75 measures of rest per one big bass wallop, which gave me plenty of time to contemplate the class warfare of the situation. And here's what I figured out. Orchestra kids wore tuxedos. Band kids wore tuxedo t-shirts. And the orchestra kids, with their brown woolens and Teutonic last names had the well-scrubbed, dark blond aura of a Hitler youth brigade. These were the sons and daughters of Humanities professors. They took German. They actually played soccer. Dumping the fluorescent t-shirts of the band kids into the orchestra each week must have looked like tossing a handful of Skittles into a bowl of Swiss chocolates.
意外经验之一——给10年级学生上的马克思主义课。每周一次，最优秀的乐队孩子会和管弦乐队一起演奏。我在管弦乐队里打大鼓，这意味着我从来没机会真正演奏。我的参与比例大约是75小节休息换一记重击，这给了我充足的时间来思考这种情况下的阶级斗争。我总结出这些：管弦乐队的孩子穿燕尾服。乐队的孩子穿印有燕尾服图案的T恤。而那些有着棕色毛呢衣服和条顿姓氏的管弦乐队孩子，有着一种被洗得干干净净、深金色的希特勒青年团气质。他们是人文学科教授的儿子和女儿。他们选修德语。他们真的踢足球。每周把乐队孩子那些荧光色T恤扔进管弦乐队，看起来一定就像把一把彩虹糖扔进一碗瑞士巧克力里一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But nothing brings kids together like hate. And the one thing the band kids and the orchestra kids had in common was a unified disgust for the chorus kids, who were to us merely drama geeks with access to four-part harmony.
但没什么比仇恨更能让孩子们团结在一起了。乐队孩子和管弦乐队孩子唯一的共同点，就是对合唱团孩子的一致厌恶，对我们来说，他们只不过是能唱四声部和声的戏剧书呆子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
A shy violin player wasn't likely to haunt the halls between classes playing "Eine Kleine Nachtmusik" any more than a band kid would blare "Land of a Thousand Dances" on his tuba more than three inches outside the band room door. But that didn't stop the choir girls from making everyone temporarily forget their locker combinations thanks to an impromptu, uncalled-for burst of "Brigadoon."
一个害羞的小提琴手不太可能在下课时在走廊里演奏《弦乐小夜曲》，乐队的孩子也不太可能在乐队室门外三英寸的地方用大号吹奏《千舞之地》。但这并不妨碍合唱团的女孩们因为突然爆发、毫无预兆的《蓬岛仙舞》（Brigadoon）合唱，让所有人暂时忘记自己的储物柜密码。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Andy Heap? Chorus.
安迪·希普？他是合唱团的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Accidental discovery number two. Where's Walter? My junior high had an electronic music lab. We made tape loops and learned words like quadraphonic. In my spare time, you know just for fun, I checked out all the books on electronic music from the library. My favorite records for a while there were Walter Carlos' concept album "Switched-On Bach" and its sequel, "The Well-Tempered Synthesizer," which offered what I thought were hilariously witty covers of Bach classics performed on-- get this-- a Moog synthesizer.
意外发现之二。瓦尔特在哪里？我的初中有电子音乐实验室。我们制作磁带循环，学习像“四声道”这样的词。空闲时间，你知道纯粹出于好玩，我从图书馆借了所有关于电子音乐的书。那段时间我最喜欢的唱片是瓦尔特·卡洛斯（Walter Carlos）的概念专辑《开关上的巴赫》（Switched-On Bach）及其续集《平均律合成器》（The Well-Tempered Synthesizer），它们提供了我当时认为非常风趣幽默的、用——你听着——Moog合成器演奏的巴赫经典曲目翻唱。
In my readings on electronic music, something puzzled me. Every time I'd look into Walter Carlos, the information would just stop and someone named Wendy Carlos would turn up. I got to school early one morning to ask my electronic music teacher what happened to Walter, and was Wendy Walter's wife or daughter? And my teacher kind of didn't answer for a long time. And then he blurted out, "uh, Wendy is Walter." What did he mean?
在我阅读电子音乐的过程中，有一件事困扰着我。每次我查阅瓦尔特·卡洛斯，资料就会戛然而止，然后一个叫温迪·卡洛斯（Wendy Carlos）的人就会冒出来。一天早上我早早去学校问电子音乐老师瓦尔特怎么了，温迪是瓦尔特的妻子还是女儿？老师沉默了很久没回答。然后他脱口而出：“呃，温迪就是瓦尔特。”他是什么意思？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Uh, Walter-- Walter had a sex change operation and changed his name to Wendy."
“呃，瓦尔特——瓦尔特做过变性手术，改名叫温迪了。”
"What's a sex change operation?"
“什么是变性手术？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Now, I know it's hard to capture now, here, in San Francisco--
现在，我知道在这里、在旧金山很难捕捉到当时的震惊——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--what a shock this was. I knew absolutely nothing about sex. We didn't talk about sex in my house and Sex Ed wasn't scheduled until spring. I was a wholesome, small town, Christian kid engaged in wholesome, small town, Christian pursuits. And suddenly, bam, I'm standing at the corner of Sodom and Gomorrah and where's my street map?
——这对当时的我是多么大的冲击。我对性一无所知。家里不谈论性，性教育课要等到春天才上。我是一个健康、小镇、虔诚的孩子，从事着健康、小镇、虔诚的活动。突然间，砰，我站在了索多玛和蛾摩拉的街角，而我的地图在哪？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That Walter Carlos. I hadn't even recovered from the shock that Bach could be messed with.
那个瓦尔特·卡洛斯。我还没从巴赫竟然可以被如此对待的震惊中恢复过来呢。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Number three, biology as destiny. In seventh grade, I started band. I wanted to play the drums. My parents, who lived with me, as was the custom in Montana, did not want me to play the drums.
第三点，生物学即命运。七年级时我开始玩乐队。我想打鼓。我父母，像蒙大拿州的习俗那样和我住在一起，不想让我打鼓。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I picked the next loudest instrument, the trumpet. How I loved my trumpet, the feel of it in my hands, its very volume and shine. You know what I especially loved? The spit valve. In eighth grade, a teacher told me about this good old trumpet player I might like, so I went out and bought one of his records. And every night for over a year I went to sleep listening to it, the same songs over and over, trying to figure out why Louis Armstrong was so funny, so moving, so good. And I got caught up in this superstar talent of his right around the time I was beginning to suspect that I didn't have it, talent, I mean.
所以我选择了下一个最响的乐器，小号。我是多么热爱我的小号，它在手中的感觉，它的音量和光泽。你知道我特别喜欢什么吗？排水阀。八年级时，一位老师告诉我一个我可能会喜欢的优秀老小号手，于是我去买了张他的唱片。连续一年多，我每天晚上都听着它入睡，同一首歌听了一遍又一遍，试图弄清楚为什么路易斯·阿姆斯特朗（Louis Armstrong）如此有趣，如此动人，如此优秀。就在我开始怀疑自己没有天赋——我是说音乐天赋——的时候，我被他的超凡才华深深吸引了。
And there was another problem too, which I discovered about three years into my trumpet career. I found out the reason I was getting a shoddy tone and I had trouble hitting the high notes was because of the shape of my jaw. The shape of my jaw. I felt the world was more or less over. I was outraged that a person's fate could depend on something as arbitrary as the angles of her teeth. And not only that, I had to switch to a brass instrument with a bigger mouthpiece, the baritone horn. The baritone horn. Like, trumpets are played by Miles Davis and baritones are played by-- nobody.
还有另一个问题，我在吹小号三年后发现了。我发现我音色差、吹不出高音的原因是因为我下巴的形状。我下巴的形状。我感到世界差不多完蛋了。我非常愤怒，一个人的命运竟然取决于牙齿角度这种随意的因素。不仅如此，我还得换一种吹口更大的铜管乐器，上低音号。上低音号。就像是，小号是由迈尔斯·戴维斯吹奏的，而上低音号是由——没人吹奏的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Lesson number four, when doves cry. From the time I was 12 until I finished high school at 18, my poor parents' calendar was blackened by an ambitious roster of concerts and recitals averaging at least one per month. They were always so gushy in their support it never dawned on me that they might have preferred to avoid junior high school gymnasium performances of the theme from Rocky . They acted as though their world revolved around my sister and me, and that's what we believed.
经验之四，当鸽子哭泣时。从我12岁直到18岁高中毕业，我可怜父母的日程表被一场野心勃勃的音乐会和演奏会填满，平均每月至少一场。他们表现出的支持总是那么夸张，以至于我从未意识到他们可能更希望避开初中体育馆里演奏的《洛奇》主题曲。他们表现得好像全世界都围绕着我和我的妹妹转，我们也就真的相信了。
But I remember one night after an eighth grade band concert, I caught a glimpse of pencil marks on my father's rolled up program. He told me that he checked each movement of each piece off as they ended.
但我记得八年级那场乐队音乐会后的一天晚上，我瞥见父亲卷起来的节目单上有铅笔痕迹。他告诉我，他每结束一个乐章就会打一个勾。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Obviously because he was counting the seconds until he could go home. And at the time, I took it badly. I was offended that he had so little regard for the seriousness of our interpretation of "What Do You Do with a Drunken Sailor?" But now I see those pathetic little check marks as heart-shaped symbols of his love. Everyone says that love requires the utmost honesty, but that's not entirely true. Once I knew that my father was suffering for my sake, really suffering, I learned that love, especially the parental kind, requires the heartwarming sacrifice that can only accompany fake enthusiasm.
显然是因为他在计算着回家的秒数。当时我觉得很受伤。我很生气，他竟然对我们演绎的《水手该怎么办？》（What Do You Do with a Drunken Sailor?）如此不屑一顾。但现在我把那些可怜的小勾看作是他爱的象征。每个人都说爱需要最大限度的诚实，但这并不完全正确。一旦我知道父亲是为了我才在忍受痛苦，真正的痛苦，我才知道爱，尤其是父母的那种爱，需要那种只有虚假热情才能带来的令人心碎的牺牲。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Number five, birth of cool. So I was doomed at the trumpet, acceptable at the baritone, shaky on this xylophone, and putrid on the piano. But there is one instrument for which I had an innate knack, an instrument I could play with some semblance of grace. It was, unfortunately, an instrument which was already on its way out during the lifetime of J.S. Bach-- the recorder. I taught myself to play it when I was 11, and by 14, I was perhaps the youngest member of the American Recorder Society, reading their journal, The American Recorder , and practicing the Elizabethan and Baroque music I special ordered with my babysitting money.
第五点，酷的诞生。我在小号上没救了，上低音号勉强及格，木琴吹得发抖，钢琴弹得糟透了。但有一种乐器我很有天赋，一种我可以带着优雅感演奏的乐器。不幸的是，那是一种在J.S.巴赫生前就已经濒临淘汰的乐器——竖笛。我在11岁时自学了竖笛，到14岁时，我可能已经是美国竖笛协会最年轻的会员，阅读他们的期刊《美国竖笛》，并用我的保姆工资特别订购伊丽莎白时代和巴洛克音乐来练习。
I found out about an amateur ensemble that met once a week in my town playing mostly Elizabethan standards like "It Was a Lover and His Lass" at a tempo marked on the metronome as "Post Office slow." The members of the Bozeman Recorder Ensemble, as we were called, included a retired high school music teacher, two math professors, and a number of housewives, one of whom had a daughter in my grade. I was the only member under the age of 40, and most of them would have been eligible for the senior citizen discount at the music store. I played with them for a couple of years until my pals Margaret and Leota and I broke off to form our own trio.
我得知在我所在的镇上每周有一次业余乐团聚会，主要演奏伊丽莎白时代的经典曲目，比如《他是恋人，她是情人》（It Was a Lover and His Lass），节奏在节拍器上标记为“邮局慢速”。波兹曼竖笛合奏团（我们是这么叫的）的成员包括一位退休高中音乐老师、两位数学教授和一些家庭主妇，其中一位的女儿和我同级。我是唯一不到40岁的成员，他们大多数人都有资格在乐器店享受老年人折扣。我和他们一起玩了几年，直到我的伙伴玛格丽特、利奥塔和我分出来组建了自己的三重奏。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The three of us just plain liked each other, liked playing. At school, in all those hours of actual classes with actual teachers, music felt more like a job. Playing with Leota and Margaret was the first time, the only time, I actually enjoyed playing music. And here's a little Elizabethan song we used to do called "Willow, Willow," which-- this is actually my first public performance since the Reagan administration.
我们三个纯粹是互相喜欢，喜欢演奏。在学校，在所有那些和老师上课的时间里，音乐更像是一份工作。和利奥塔、玛格丽特一起演奏是我第一次，也是唯一一次真正享受音乐。这是一首我们曾经演奏的小小的伊丽莎白时代歌曲，叫《柳树，柳树》（Willow, Willow）——这其实是我自里根政府以来的首次公开表演。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which I was kind of looking forward to. And on my way here, I was walking down Market, and there was this guy on the street playing the recorder. And I kind of got a glimpse of what that looks like.
我很期待这次演出。在来这里的路上，我在市场街上走着，看到一个家伙在街上吹竖笛。我算是瞥见了那看起来是什么样子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm a little less sure. So this is "Willow, Willow" from a manuscript in the British museum.
我有点不那么确定了。所以，这是来自大英博物馆手稿里的《柳树，柳树》。
[PLAYING RECORDER]
[吹竖笛]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Now, imagine playing that on the street with your two friends who happen to be older than your parents. And you look up from your music stand and notice one of your schoolmates staring on in horror-- Andy Heap, for instance. But you know what? You don't care. You might even smile at him. And this is the most important lesson of marching band, of public displays of recorder-- to withstand embarrassment. Maybe even seek it out. To take nerdiness to its most dizzying, "Willow, Willow," "Tico-Tico" extremes--
现在，想象一下和你那比你父母年纪还大的两个朋友在街上吹这个。你从谱架上抬起头，发现你的一个同学正惊恐地盯着看——比如安迪·希普。但你知道吗？你根本不在乎。你甚至可能会对他微笑。这就是行进乐队、竖笛公开表演教给我最重要的东西——抵御尴尬。甚至去寻找尴尬。将书呆子气发挥到令人眩晕的、《柳树，柳树》、《Tico-Tico》的极端——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--and stand before my peers with my head held high, to stick out my tongue at the Andy Heaps of the world, run back to the baritone horn of life, and blow mighty and proud.
——站在同龄人面前，昂着头，向世界上的安迪·希普们吐舌头，跑回生命的上低音号前，吹出强大而自豪的声音。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
(HOST) SARAH VOWELL: Thank you.
（主持人）萨拉·沃威尔：谢谢。
Sarah Vowell is the music columnist for the online magazine Salon and the author of Radio On .
萨拉·沃威尔是在线杂志《沙龙》（Salon）的音乐专栏作家，《电台开播》（Radio On）一书的作者。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
One, two, three--
一，二，三——
[MUSIC - CHILDREN FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT]
[音乐 - 来自旧金山联合学区的孩子们]
Act Three, Knockin' on Heaven's Door. In this act, we turn from formal music lessons to what it is that music can actually teach us today now, outside the classroom. Anne Lamott is the only writer in our show today who actually lives in the San Francisco area. The author of many books, please welcome her.
第三幕，《敲响天堂之门》。在这一幕中，我们从正式的音乐课转向音乐今天在教室外能教给我们的东西。安妮·拉莫特是我们节目中唯一真正住在旧金山地区的作家。她是多本书的作者，欢迎她。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you. So there I was on a plane returning home from St. Louis. Or rather, there I was in a plane on the runway at the airport in St. Louis, with, I think, the not unreasonable expectation that we would be in the air soon as our flight had already been delayed two hours. I was anxious to get home, as I had not seen Sam in several days. But all things considered, I thought I was coping quite well, especially because I am a skeptical and terrified flier. In between devouring Hershey's chocolates and $13 worth of trashy magazines, I had spent the two hours of the delay trying to be helpful to the other stranded passengers. I distributed all my magazines and most of my chocolates, I got an old man some water, I flirted with babies, I mingled, I schmoozed, I was Geoffrey Rush in Shine.
谢谢。我当时正坐在一架从圣路易斯回家的飞机上。或者说，我当时坐在圣路易斯机场跑道上的一架飞机里，我认为我们很快就能起飞的期待并非不合理，因为我们的航班已经延误了两个小时。我很想回家，因为我已经好几天没见到萨姆了。但总的来说，我认为我应对得还不错，特别是作为一个怀疑论者和恐飞者。在两个小时的延误中，除了吞掉好时巧克力和价值13美元的垃圾杂志外，我一直试图帮助其他滞留的乘客。我分发了所有的杂志和大部分巧克力，给一位老人倒了水，和婴儿调情，社交，谈笑风生，我简直就是电影《闪亮的风采》里的杰弗里·拉什。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I had seen what may have been a miracle at my church recently. I had been feeling ever since that I was supposed to walk through life with a deeper faith, a deeper sense of assurance that if I took care of God's children for God, He would take care of me. My only hope was that nothing else go wrong, that once we were on board, everything runs smoothly. My idea of everything running smoothly on an airplane is that once it is in the air, A, I not die in a slow-motion fiery crash or get stabbed to death by terrorists. And that B, none of the other passengers try to talk to me.
我最近在教堂里见过一次可能的神迹。从那以后，我一直觉得我应该带着更深厚的信仰走过一生，深信如果我为上帝照看祂的孩子，祂也会照看我。我唯一的希望是别再出什么岔子，一旦上了飞机，一切顺利。我在飞机上对“顺利”的定义是：一旦起飞，A，我不会死于慢动作的火球坠毁，或者被恐怖分子刺死。B，其他的乘客别试图跟我说话。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We finally got to board. I was in row 38 between a woman slightly older than I with limited language skills and a man my own age who was reading a book by a famous right-wing Christian novelist about the apocalypse. A newspaper had asked me to review it when it first came out because this author and I are both Christians, although, as I pointed out in my review, he's one of those right-wing Christians who think that Jesus is coming back sometime next Tuesday right after lunch, and I am one of those left-wing Christians who think that perhaps the author is just spiritualizing his hysteria.
我们终于登机了。我坐在38排，邻座是一位语言能力有限、比我大一点的妇女，和一位和我同龄的男人，他正在读一本关于启示录的著名右翼基督徒小说家写的书。书刚出来时一家报纸让我写书评，因为这位作者和我都是基督徒，尽管正如我在书评中指出的那样，他是那种认为耶稣将在下周二午餐后回来的右翼基督徒，而我则是那种认为作者可能只是在对他自己的歇斯底里进行精神化解读的左翼基督徒。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Also, I suggested in my review that he has the tendency to be a little rigid. "How is it?" I ask, pointing jovially to his book, partly to be friendly and partly to gauge where he stood politically.
此外，我在书评中建议他有一种变得有点僵化的倾向。“写得怎么样？”我指着他的书愉快地问，一部分是为了友好，一部分是为了试探他的政治立场。
"This is one of the best books I've ever read," he replied. "You should read it." I nodded. I remember saying in the review that it was hardcore, right-wing paranoid, anti-semitic, homophobic, misogynistic propaganda.
“这是我读过最好的书之一，”他回答。“你应该读一读。”我点点头。我记得我在书评里说它是硬核的、右翼的、偏执的、反犹的、同性恋恐惧的、厌女的宣传。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Not to put too fine a point on it.
这已经说得很客气了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He smiled and went back to reading. I couldn't begin to guess what country the woman was from, although I think it's possible that she had one Latvian parent and one Korean. She sounded a little Latka, the Andy Kaufman character on Taxi , except when things began to fall apart, when she sounded just like the space men in Mars Attacks! "Ack! Ack! Ack!," she'd cry. But I'm getting ahead of myself.
他笑了笑，继续阅读。我无法猜测那位妇女来自哪个国家，但我认为她可能有一个拉脱维亚父亲和一个韩国母亲。她的声音听起来有点像电视剧《出租车》里的安迪·考夫曼角色拉特卡（Latka），除了当事情开始崩溃时，听起来就像电影《火星人玩转地球》里的太空人！“Ack！Ack！Ack！”她会叫。但我说远了。
As we sat there on the runway, the man reading the book about the apocalypse commented on the small gold cross I wear on a necklace. "Are you born again?" He asked as we taxied down the runway. He was rather prim and tense, maybe a little like David Eisenhower with a spastic colon.
当我们坐在跑道上时，那个读启示录书的男人评论了我脖子上戴的小金十字架。“你是重生了吗？”我们在跑道上滑行时他问。他相当古板和紧张，也许有点像有肠痉挛的戴维·艾森豪威尔。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I did not know how to answer for a moment. "Yes," I said, finally, "I am." My friends like to tell each other that I am not really a born-again Christian. They think of me more along the lines of that old Jonathan Miller routine when he said, "I'm not really a Jew. I'm Jew-ish."
我一时不知道该怎么回答。“是的，”我终于说，“我是。”我的朋友们喜欢互相开玩笑说我不是一个真正的重生基督徒。他们认为我更像乔纳森·米勒那个老段子里说的：“我不是真正的犹太人。我只是‘犹太气’（Jew-ish）。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They think I'm Christian-ish. But I'm not. I'm just a bad Christian. A bad born-again Christian. And certainly, like the apostle Peter, I am capable of denying it, of presenting myself as a sort of leftist, liberation theology enthusiast, and maybe sort of vaguely Jesus-y bon vivant.
他们认为我是“基督徒气”。但其实不是。我只是一个坏基督徒。一个坏的重生基督徒。当然，就像使徒彼得一样，我有能力否认它，把自己表现为一个左翼、解放神学爱好者，也许是一个有点模糊的耶稣式享乐主义者。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But it's not true. And I believe when you get on a plane, if you start lying, you are screwed unto the very Lord.
但这不是事实。我相信当你上一架飞机时，如果你开始撒谎，那你就在上帝面前完蛋了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I told the truth, that I'm a believer, a convert. I'm probably about three months away from slapping an aluminum Jesus fish on the back of my car. Although I first want to see if the application or Stickum in any way interferes with my lease agreement.
所以我说了实话，我是一个信徒，一个改宗者。我离在车屁股上贴一个铝制的耶稣鱼标志可能只有三个月的时间了。尽管我首先得看看那种粘合剂会不会干扰我的租赁协议。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I just love the guy. I just love Jesus. It's that simple. Anyway, as the plane taxied out to the runway, the man on my right began telling me about how he and his wife were home schooling their children. And he described with enormous acrimony the radical, free-for-all, feminist, artsy-feely philosophy of his county school system. And I knew instantly that this description was an act of aggression against me, that he was telepathic onto me, could see that I am the enemy, that I will be on the same curling team in Heaven as Tom Hayden and Vanessa Redgrave.
我就是爱那个家伙。我就是爱耶稣。就这么简单。总之，当飞机滑向跑道时，右边的男人开始告诉我他和妻子是如何在家教孩子。他带着巨大的敌意描述了所在县学校系统的激进、自由、女权主义、艺术感性的哲学。我立刻知道这种描述是对我的侵略，他看穿了我，能看出我是敌人，我和汤姆·海登、瓦妮莎·雷德格雷夫在天堂里会是在同一个冰壶队。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But suddenly the plane braked to a stop. We all looked around for a moment, and then the captain came on the PA system and announced calmly that two passengers wanted to get off the plane right then and there. We were headed back to the gate. "What?" we all cried. The good news was that this was only going to take a minute or so, since in the past two hours we'd only gotten about 500 feet. The bad news was that FAA regulations dictated that all of the stowed luggage had to be gone over by security to make sure these people had not accidentally left behind their pipe bombs.
但突然飞机刹停了。我们都环顾四周，然后机长通过广播平静地宣布，有两名乘客现在就要下飞机。我们要回登机口了。“什么？”我们都喊道。好消息是这只需要一两分钟，因为在过去的两个小时里，我们只滑行了500英尺。坏消息是，联邦航空管理局规定所有存放的行李都必须经过安检，以确保这些人没有不小心留下什么土制炸弹。
The Latvian woman stared at me quizzically. I explained very slowly and very loudly what was going on. She gaped at me for a moment. "Ack," she whispered.
那位拉脱维亚妇女困惑地盯着我。我非常缓慢且大声地解释发生了什么。她愣了一会儿。“Ack，”她低声说。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Eventually, the three of us in row 38 began to read. And an hour later, the plane finally took off again. We, the citizens of row 38, all ordered sodas. The Latvian woman put on a Walkman and began to listen with her eyes closed. The Christian man read his book about the apocalypse. I read The New Yorker . Then the seat belt sign came on and the pilot came back on over the PA system. "I'm afraid we're about to hit some really heavy turbulence," he said. "Please return to your seats."
最终，38排的三个人开始阅读。一小时后，飞机终于再次起飞了。我们，38排的公民，全都点了饮料。那位拉脱维亚妇女戴上随身听，闭着眼睛听起来。基督徒男人读他的启示录书。我读《纽约客》。然后安全带指示灯亮起，飞行员再次通过广播。“恐怕我们要遇到严重的湍流了，”他说。“请回到座位上。”
A moment later the plane began bouncing around so hard that we had to hold on to our drinks. "Ack! Ack! Ack!" said the Latvian, grabbing for her Sprite. "Everyone take your seat!" the pilot literally barked over the PA system. "We are in for some rough going." My heart bounced around like a jumping bean. The plane rose and fell and shook, and the pilot came back on and said sternly, like an angry dad, "flight attendants, sit down now!"
片刻之后，飞机开始剧烈颠簸，我们不得不抓住饮料。“Ack！Ack！Ack！”拉脱维亚妇女说，抓着她的雪碧。“每个人回到座位上！”飞行员在广播里大喊。“我们要经历一段颠簸了。”我的心像跳豆一样乱跳。飞机起伏摇晃，飞行员又严厉地说，就像一个愤怒的爸爸，“空乘人员，现在坐下！”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the plane hit those waves and currents of air on the choppy sea of sky, and we bounced and moaned and gasped. "Whoa," we all said, as one, like we were on a roller coaster ride. We're going down, I thought. I know a basic tenet of the Christian faith is that death is really just a major change of address--
飞机撞上了那片浑浊天空海洋里的气流，我们颠簸、呻吟、喘气。“哇，”我们异口同声地说，就像在坐过山车。我们要坠毁了，我想。我知道基督教信仰的一个基本教义是死亡其实只是换了个地址——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--but I had to close my eyes to squinch back tears of terror and loss. Oh my god, I thought. Oh my god. I'll never see Sam again. This will kill me a second time. The plane bucked and shook without stopping, and the Christian read calmly, stoically, rather pleased with himself it seemed to my tiny, hysterical self. The Latvian closed her eyes and turned up her Walkman. I could hear it playing softly.
——但我不得不闭上眼睛，硬挤出恐怖和失去的泪水。哦，我的上帝，我想。哦，我的上帝。我再也见不到萨姆了。这会让我第二次死亡。飞机不停地颠簸摇晃，而那个基督徒读得很从容、冷淡，在我这小小的、歇斯底里的自我看来，他好像很自得其乐。拉脱维亚妇女闭上眼睛，调高了随身听音量。我能听到它在轻轻播放。
And I, praying for another miracle, thought about the one I had just seen. It took place at my church, where one of our newer members, a man named Ken, is dying of AIDS, disintegrating before our very eyes. He came in a year ago with a Jewish woman who comes every week to be with us, although she does not believe in Jesus. Shortly after the man with AIDS started coming, his partner died of the disease. A few weeks later, he said that right then and there, in the hole in his heart that Brandon's death left, Jesus slid in and had been there ever since. This man has a totally lopsided face, ravaged, emaciated. And when he smiles, he's radiant. He looks like God's crazy nephew Phil.
而我，祈求另一个神迹，想到了我刚刚见过的那一个。它发生在我们教堂里，我们的一位新成员，一个叫肯的男人正在死于艾滋病，在我们眼前消融。他一年前带着一位犹太妇女来，她每周都来和我们在一起，尽管她不信耶稣。那个有艾滋病的男人开始来教堂后不久，他的伴侣就死于这种病了。几周后，他说就在那时那地，在布兰登去世留下的心里空洞里，耶稣滑了进来，从那以后就一直呆在那里。这个男人脸完全歪了，残破不堪，骨瘦如柴。当他微笑时，他是容光焕发的。他看起来就像上帝那疯癫的侄子菲尔。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He said that he would gladly pay any price for what he has now, which is Jesus and us. There's a woman in the choir named Renola, a beautiful black woman who is smart and jovial and sweet and as devout as can be but who has also been a little standoffish towards Ken, if you ask me. She's always looked at him with confusion, when she looks at him at all, in his goofy, ravaged joy. Or she looks at him sideways. She was raised by Baptists in the Midwest who must have thought that his way of life, that he, was an abomination.
他说他愿意为他现在所拥有的付出任何代价，也就是耶稣和我们。合唱团里有个叫雷诺拉的女人，一位美丽的黑人女性，聪明、愉快、甜美，极其虔诚，但她对肯却有点冷淡，如果你问我。她总是带着困惑看着他，如果她看他的话，看着他那滑稽、残破的喜悦。或者她斜眼看着他。她在中西部的浸信会家庭长大，一定认为他的生活方式，他本人，是一种可憎之物。
Maybe it was hard for her to break through this. Maybe on the most visceral level, she was a little afraid of catching the disease. I'm not sure. But anyway, Kenny has come to church almost every week for the last year and won almost everyone else over. He missed a couple of Sundays a while ago because he was too weak to come. And then a month ago, he came back, weighing almost no pounds, his face even more lopsided, as if he's had a stroke. But during the Prayers of the People, he talked joyously of his life and his decline, of how safe and happy he feels these days.
也许她很难突破这一点。也许在最本能的层面上，她有点害怕被传染上这种病。我不确定。但总之，肯尼几乎每周都来教堂，并在过去一年里赢得了几乎所有人的心。前一阵子他错过了几个周日，因为他太虚弱了，无法前来。一个月前，他回来了，体重几乎为零，脸歪得更厉害了，就像中风过一样。但在会众祈祷期间，他欢快地谈论着他的生命和他的衰退，谈论着他这些日子感到多么安全和快乐。
So on this one particular Sunday, for the first hymn, the so-called morning hymn, we sang "Jacob's Ladder," which goes "every rung goes higher, higher." But Kenny couldn't stand. But he sang away, sitting down, with a hymnal in his lap. And then when it came time for the second hymn, the fellowship hymn, we sang "His Eye is on the Sparrow." I noticed that Ken still couldn't stand up to sing. The pianist was playing and the whole congregation had risen. And only Ken remained seated, holding the hymnal in his lap.
所以在那一个特定的周日，第一首赞美诗，所谓的晨祷诗，我们唱了《雅各的天梯》，歌词是“每一级都更高，更高”。但肯尼站不起来。他坐着唱歌，膝盖上放着一本赞美诗集。当第二首诗，团契赞美诗的时间到了，我们唱了《祂注视着麻雀》（His Eye is on the Sparrow）。我注意到肯尼仍然无法站起来唱歌。钢琴家在弹奏，全体会众都起立了。只有肯尼坐着，膝盖上拿着赞美诗集。
And Renola watched him rather skeptically for a moment. And then her face began to melt and contort like his. And she went to his side and bent down to lift him up, lifted up this white rag doll, this scarecrow. She held him next to her and he was draped over and against her like a child. And they sang. And it pierced me.
雷诺拉怀疑地看了他一会儿。然后她的脸开始像他一样融化和扭曲。她走到他身边，弯下腰扶起他，扶起这个白色的布娃娃，这个稻草人。她把他抱在身边，他像孩子一样披在她身上靠着她。他们唱着。这刺痛了我。
I can't imagine anything else but music that could have brought about this alchemy. How is it that you have a chord here and then another chord there and then your heart breaks open? I don't know the answer. Maybe it's that music is about as physical as it gets. Your essential rhythm is your heartbeat. Your essential sound, the breath. We're walking temples of noise. And when you add the human heart to this mix, it somehow lets us meet on a bridge we couldn't get to any other way.
除了音乐，我想不出还有什么能带来这种炼金术。为什么这里有一个和弦，那里有另一个和弦，你的心就破碎了？我不知道答案。也许音乐就是物理上的极致。你本质的节奏就是你的心跳。你本质的声音就是呼吸。我们是行走的噪音庙宇。当你把人类的心灵加入这个混合物中，它就以某种方式让我们在以前无法到达的桥梁上相遇。
Back on board, little by little, the plane grew steadier. And the pilot came back on to say that everything was OK. I was so excited that we were not going to crash and that I might actually get to see Sam again that I started feeling mingle-y. I suddenly wanted to be new best friends with a Christian man. But just when I opened my mouth, the pilot came back on the PA system and asked if there was a doctor on board. The woman behind us who turned out to be a nurse got up and went back to investigate. The Christian man prayed. I tried to rubberneck but I couldn't see a thing.
回到飞机上，飞机渐渐平稳了。飞行员回来说一切都好。我很兴奋，我们不会坠毁，我也许真的能再见到萨姆，我开始感到想要社交了。我突然想和那个基督徒男人成为新好朋友。但就在我张嘴时，飞行员在广播里问有没有医生在机上。我们身后那个后来发现是护士的女人站起来去调查。那个基督徒男人祈祷。我试图伸长脖子，但我什么也看不见。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I went back to thinking about Ken in my church, and how on that Sunday Ken, of whom Renola had been so skeptical, was trying to sing. But then he and Renola both began to cry. Tears were pouring down their faces, and their noses were running like rivers. But as she held him up, she suddenly lay her black, weeping face against his feverish white face, put hers right up against his, and let all those spooky fluids mingle with her. He looked like a child in her arms who was singing because tiny children just sing all the time because they haven't made all the separations between speech and music. So he sang and she held him up. And she sang and he held her up.
我回到关于我教堂里肯尼的思考中，以及那个雷诺拉曾如此怀疑的肯尼在那个周日是怎么试图唱歌的。但随后他和雷诺拉都开始哭泣。泪水流下他们的脸颊，鼻涕像河水一样流。但当她扶着他时，她突然把她哭泣的黑色脸庞贴在他发烫的白皙脸颊上，把她的脸贴在他脸上，让所有那些怪异的体液与她混合。他看起来就像她怀里的一个孩子，在唱歌，因为小孩子总是唱歌，因为他们还没在说话和音乐之间划出界限。所以他唱着，她扶着他。她唱着，他扶着她。
When the nurse sitting beside us returned to row 39, it was with the news that a woman in the back was having a heart attack. A heart attack. I ask you. But there were doctors on hand and the nurse thought the woman was going to be OK. "Good lord," said the Christian man. We looked at each other and sighed. We shook our heads and continued to look at each other. "God," I said, "I just hope the snakes don't get out of the cargo hold."
当坐在我们身边的护士回到39排时，带来的消息是后面的一名妇女心脏病发作了。心脏病发作。我问你。但手头有医生，护士认为那个妇女会没事的。“天哪，”那个基督徒男人说。我们对视一眼，叹了口气。我们摇摇头，继续看着对方。“上帝，”我说，“我只希望货舱里的蛇别跑出来。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The prim, apocalyptic Christian man smiled. Then he laughed out loud. The Latvian woman started laughing then, although she still had her Walkman on. And while I hate to look like I'm enjoying my own jokes too much, I started laughing too. The three of us sat there in hysterics. And when we were done, the man reached over and patted the back of my hand, smiling gently. The Latvian woman leaned in close to me, into my Soviet air space, and--
那个古板的、启示录式的基督徒男人笑了。然后他大声笑出声来。拉脱维亚妇女开始笑了，尽管她还戴着随身听。虽然我不喜欢看起来太享受自己的笑话，但我也开始笑了。我们三个人歇斯底里地坐在那里。当我们笑完时，男人伸手拍了拍我的手背，温柔地笑着。拉脱维亚妇女向我倾斜，进入了我的苏联领空，然后——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--she beamed. I leaned forward so that our foreheads touched for just a second. I thought, I do not know if what happened at church was an honest-to-God little miracle. And I don't know if there has been another one here, the smallest possible sort. But now I felt like I was sitting with my cousins on a plane eight miles up, a plane that was going to make it home. And it made me so happy that I suddenly thought, this is plenty of miracle for me to rest in now.
——她灿烂地笑了。我向前倾，让我们的额头触碰了一秒钟。我想，我不知道教堂里发生的究竟是不是一个真正的小奇迹。我不知道这里是否又发生了一个，那种最小可能的奇迹。但现在我觉得我正和我的表亲们坐在八英里高空的飞机上，一架能回家的飞机。这让我感到如此快乐，以至于我突然想，这就足够让我安歇的奇迹了。
[SINGING "HIS EYE IS ON THE SPARROW"]
[歌唱《祂注视着麻雀》]
Anne Lamott is the author of Bird by Bird, Operating Instructions, and most recently, Crooked Little Heart. Singing from Renola Garrison and the pianist is Anne Jefferson, both of them from Anne's church.
安妮·拉莫特是《鸟类》（Bird by Bird）、《操作指南》（Operating Instructions）和最近的作品《扭曲的小心》（Crooked Little Heart）的作者。演唱者是雷诺拉·加里森，钢琴伴奏是安妮·杰斐逊，她们都来自安妮的教堂。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Engineering by Joe Hunter.
今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。高级编辑保罗·托夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。乔·亨特负责工程。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our show was produced for the stage by Kate Boyd and the Solo Mio Festival. Addition music by David Riera. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. It has been such a thrill being here. Back next week with more stores of This American Life.
我们的节目由凯特·博伊德和“Solo Mio”艺术节制作。大卫·里拉提供补充音乐。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。能在这里主持简直太激动人心了。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Today's program was first broadcast in 1998. This American Life was distributed by Public Radio International.
今天的节目于1998年首播。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金捐助名单]
PRI. Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。